alors comment réagir face à cette
épidémie alors que l'italie a placé 15
millions de personnes en quarantaine la
france elle aussi doit prendre des
mesures quelles sont-elles d'hôtel
suivent les entre l'exemple transalpin
quelle est la marge de manoeuvre des
gouvernements sur le plan de la santé
publique mais aussi sur la question de
l'économie c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir et pour en débattre nous
sommes en direct avec le docteur laurent
alexandre entrepreneur et essayiste
bonsoir laurent docteur laurent
alexandre merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france sur ce plateau à
paris ferghana ziari chargé d'études
pour l'institut de recherches
économiques et fiscales merci à vous
d'être là aussi à leur première question
messieurs votre réaction un petit peu
globale sur ce climat assez irréaliste
en ce moment docteur à laurent alexandre
ben c'est un virus nouveau
c'est à dire que nous ne connaissons pas
encore la vie et les us et coutumes de
ce virus notamment nous ne savons pas si
le coronavirus va se calmer quand il
fait plus chaud
d'habitude les virus respiratoires
s'améliore lorsque la température
augmente et lorsqu elle est juive est
arrivé lorsqu'il ya plus de soleil mais
on n'en est pas certain pour le corps à
des russes donc on est face à une grande
incertitude
ce qui explique que la position du
ministère de la santé ne soit pas facile
pour vous on n'en fait pas trop c'est
normal d'avoir finalement aussi peur
parce que il semblerait que la psychose
gagne peu à peu
c'est en tout cas l'impression qu'on en
a quand on allume sa télé le matin alors
il est normal de prendre des démesures
puisqu'il n'y a pas de vaccin contre le
port navires us pour l'instant il n'y a
pas non plus de médicaments donc la
seule façon d'éviter que les gens la
trappe c'est de limiter les contacts
donc ce que fait le ministère de la
santé en france et vous paraît tout à
fait raisonnable et ce que fait le
ministre de la santé
olivier derand et est aujourd'hui
l'optimum
il faut gagner du temps on aura pas de
vaccin
le coronavirus avant de nombreux mois
donc il faut aujourd'hui prendre en
charge les malades et notamment les
malades les plus fragiles les plus
graves
et puis il faut éviter que les gens se
contaminent comme dans toute infection
virale
quand vous dites il faut gagner du temps
pourquoi est-ce aussi important de
gagner du temps justement pour avoir le
temps de me trouver des remèdes un
vaccin que vous évoquez surtout parce
que en hiver les places dans les
services de pneumologie et dans les
services de réanimation sont utilisés
pour les gentils jour des pneumonies et
notamment pour les personnes âgées par
exemple à la suite d'un épisode grippal
donc on ne peut pas gérer facilement en
même temps l'embolisation des hôpitaux
par les grippes crabe et puis par le
coronavirus faut savoir qu'en france la
grippe ces dix mille morts chaque année
il y a donc de nombreuses places en
cardiologie en pneumologie et dans les
services de réanimation qui sont
utilisées par des malades qui ont eu une
grippe grave quand on arrive au
printemps les la grippe diminue et donc
il ya plus de places en réanimation pour
les malades qui ont un coronavirus donc
à plusieurs mesures qui ont été
annoncées pour la france en tant qu un
huis clos pour les matchs concerts
annulés rassemblement de plus de 1000
personnes proscrit ça vous paraît trop
la bonne solution fergane asia c'est une
question assez difficile parce que
laurent alexandre l'a rappelé il ya
beaucoup d'incertitudes sur ce virus et
ça pose la question des risques qu'on
est prêt à prendre
en fait c'est à dire que le le problème
c'est que l'aversion au risque est
quelque chose de subjectif certaines
personnes seront très insouciante et
continueront à vivre malgré le risque
d'être contaminé d'autres beaucoup plus
fragiles seront beaucoup plus frileux et
et considérons que le moindre risque est
tout à fait intolérable et préférons
donc ceux restés confinés où ma part je
ne suis pas médecin donc je vais pas me
prononcer sur les questions de santé
mais c'est vrai que à titre personnel je
suis assez réticent à l'idée qu'il
fallait s'arrêter de vivre
en raison de cette épidémie mais encore
une fois cela relève aussi de la
perception individuelle en une fois
l'aversion au risque est trop subjective
certaines personnes vont préférer vont
continuer à vivre et vont prendre le
risque de s'exposer si la trappe et bien
cela relèvera aussi de leur
responsabilité individuelle et d'autres
préférons être plus prudent je pense que
c'est à chacun de prendre ses
responsabilités ici en fonction de sa
santé est effectivement les personnes
âgées les gens qui ont des pathologies
et serait d'être plus responsable pour
elle de limiter leurs déplacements de
rester chez elle essaie de sortir le
moins possible et a contrario inverse
ceux qui peuvent se le permettre
on ne peut pas non plus bloquer tout un
pays tout une économie ça aurait des
répercussions sur la vie des gens qui
pourraient être encore plus
problématique que si les gens ne peuvent
plus subvenir à leurs besoins c'est
quelque chose de tout aussi
problématique que qu'une ça peut être
aussi assez grave ça veut dire que nous
on doit prendre nos responsabilités en
tant que citoyen vous attendez beaucoup
vous par exemple du gouvernement ces
mesures
voilà ces empêchements les gens qui
voulaient aller au concert au match est
ce que c'est une bonne chose
de les interdire justement parce que là
c'est pas prendre ses responsabilités
c'est le gouvernement coup oui c'est mon
train lice c'est vrai que le
gouvernement alors le gouvernement dans
une position délicate parce que il les a
poussés par l'opinion publique à réagir
de manière ferme puisque a posteriori si
il ne prend pas ces mesures
il sera accusé par les populations de ne
pas avoir fait grand chose il ya un
billet toujours pro action qui fait que
même si on n'est pas certain de
l'efficacité de telle ou telle mesure il
faut quand même la prendre pour
satisfaire les opinions publiques
ceci dit il ne faut pas non plus verser
dans les séries il faut être aussi sûr
que les mesures que l'on prend ne ne
rajoute pas des problèmes
supplémentaires et de mesures qui me
vient à l'esprit c'est la volonté
d'interdire de plafonner les prix
notamment des gels hydroalcooliques
alors bruno le maire a pris cette mesure
de manière assez énergétique pour
montrer qu'il fait quelque chose
mais économistes vous disent tous que
lorsqu'il ya une offre qui qui est
limitée une demande qui explose
plafonner les prix ça ne sert
strictement à rien vous allez juste créé
la pénurie supplémentaires et rendre ses
produits la moins accessible encore pour
les populations
donc voilà typiquement un jeu une seule
genre de mesure complètement démagogique
qui ne sert à rien si ce n'est à
accélérer les pénuries dans les
pharmacies et qui va peut-être contenter
les les opinions qui attend des
gouvernements qu'ils agissent très
activement sans pour autant observé un
quelconque effet positif sur la santé
des populations leur alexandre vous avez
salué l'action numi's la santé mais
alors voilà typiquement ce genre de
mesure vous vous êtes en accord avec
vraiment toutes les mesures annoncées
par le gouvernement
monsieur a dit harry ou vous parlez nous
parler de ces gels mans fayat jeu le
cités plus haut l'interdiction des
matchs des concerts des rassemblements
une 1000 personnes on est dans la bonne
voie en agissant ainsi
oui alors je suis d'accord avec ses
organes le plein sonné le prix et gèle
ça va juste conduire au marché noir des
du dégel comme d'habitude parce que s'il
ya une demande très forte qu'on bloque
les prix bas y en aura pas pour tout le
monde donc ça c'est une mesure qui est
effectivement démagogique
les mesures qui ont été prises par le
ministère de la santé et par le
gouvernement pour limiter
rencontre très de foule nombreuse sont
raisonnables c'est une limitation à nos
libertés mais qui n'était que temporaire
personnellement je les approuve ce que
je devrais dire sur ce virus et qu' il
faut raison garder entre 1900 et 1977 de
l'éradication sur terre de la variole la
variole a tué 300 millions de personnes
chaque année avant le vaccin la rougeole
tué six millions d'enfants sur terre le
sida a tué 36 millions de personnes sur
terre la grippe les années où elle est
un peu forte tue un million de personnes
sur terre et en 1919 elle a tué entre 50
et 100 millions de personnes donc le
coronavirus n'est pas un virus qui pour
l'instant a entraîné des désastres aussi
important que les grandes pandémies
virale du 20e siècle et surtout cette
pandémie ne change rien l'idée que le
monde ne serait pas plus sûr et en
meilleure santé s'ils étaient fermés moi
je mets ferait davantage la démagogie de
ceux qui nous explique aujourd'hui que
on n'aurait jamais dû s'ouvrir comme un
certain nationale et que les
perturbations sur les chaînes
d'approvisionnement
ce réel à la prétendue preuve qu'il ne
fallait jamais entretenir des liens de
dépendance aussi fort à l'égard de
l'étranger et au contraire si les
maladies que je viens de citer
laurent alexandre font aujourd'hui aussi
peu de victimes et ont commencé à
reculer au cours du 20e siècle c'est
précisément grâce à l'ouverture du
commerce grâce au fait que la
mondialisation à consolider une
industrie pharmaceutique et médical
productive capable de mettre aujourd'hui
à disposition à l' échelle massive des
médicaments et cela n'aurait pas été
possible simplement dans un contexte de
tharsis je crois qu'il faut être assez
démagogique pour ne pas dire
complètement idiot pour dire que la
corée du nord aujourd'hui serait dans un
état sanitaire beaucoup plus enviable au
motif qu'elle est fermée contrairement
aux autres pays
du monde si oui tout ferghana à fait
raison la corée du nord montre ce qu'est
un pays qui ferme ses frontières si nous
fermions en nos frontières nous serions
tous très pauvre et nous aurions la
médecine des années 1930 et nous prendre
au rayon énormément de risques donc les
gens qui proposent la fermeture des
frontières les gens qui proposent la fin
du commerce international en réalité
nous propose de nous appauvrir et de
nous conduire à une époque pour ne
savaient pas traiter les dix russes où
on ne s'arrête pas traiter les
infections
c'est bien parce que le commerce
international nous a enrichis et à
développer la technologie notamment
médicale conte et oblige on est
aujourd'hui plus serein face aux
coronavirus qu'on l'était jadis face à
la variole et surtout l'idée qu'il
faille tout simplement réduire notre
dépendance à l'égard de l'étranger
sous-entend que notre pays serait par
essence immunisé contre l'imprévu ce qui
est là encore complètement idiot demandé
aux africains de l'est qui actuellement
voir le voient leurs récoltes ravagés
par des nuées de criquets s'il faut
qu'ils s'abstiennent de toute dépendance
extérieure
c'est précisément grâce au commerce que
ces gens pourront importer les dorés qui
leur manquent à l'échelle locale à cause
de l'imprévisible donc le risque zéro
n'existe nulle part et n'existe ni dans
les sociétés ouvertes néracais faire le
vide et puis d'acheter des pesticides
parce que contre les criquets la seule
chose qu'on sait faire ce sont les
pesticides
ce n'est pas l'agriculture bio qui va
permettre de lutter contre les criquets
alors il n'empêche monsieur ça ne vous a
pas évidemment pas échappé les marchés
accusé des plongeons monstre a
aujourd'hui en tout cas comparables à
ceux de 2008
est ce que ce n'est pas là justement une
façon de peut-être de changer certains
en tout cas de remettre en cause notre
modèle est ce qu'on n'est pas trop
dépendants effectivement de certains
pays comme la chine cette fébrilité
économique ne vous inquiétez pas vous
elle est temporaire c'est à dire que on
a effectivement nous et d
interdépendance avec de nombreux pays du
monde dont la chine les chaînes
d'approvisionnement sont aujourd'hui
perturbé à cause de cette pandémie
mais lorsque cet épisode sera derrière
nous je pense et je suis certain que ces
chaînes vont se reconstituer c'est à
dire que quand une fois on a toujours
intérêt à l'ouverture
l' avantage aussi du libre échange c'est
la capacité à diversifier les sources
d'approvisionnement donc s'ouvrir et se
rendre dépendant du monde ne veut pas
dire perdre tout résilience si aussi la
capacité pour les firmes de relocaliser
temporairement leurs chaînes
d'approvisionnement
c'est lent c'est laborieux ça ne se fait
pas comme ça d'un claquement de doigts
mais c'est possible moi je suis
convaincu encore une fois que lorsque
toute cette pandémie sera derrière nous
à les entreprises relocaliseront parce
que cette internationalisation de la
division du travail
elle correspond aussi à la demande des
consommateurs des demandes de produits à
des prix toujours plus faibles ceux ci
se prive de ce commerce national
inutilement pour des raisons
irrationnelle seront totalement balayés
par la concurrence de ceux qui géreront
leur chaîne d'approvisionnement
plus raisonnablement en
localisant les productions là où elles
sont les plus optimales laurent
alexandre je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit fergane moi je voudrais
donner un message d'optimisme en 1348
quand la grande peste est arrivée elle a
tué en milieu 40% des européens
quatre européens sur dix sont mort de la
peste et il n'y avait pas de traitement
vu le premier traitement contre la peste
et la tétracycline en 1948 c'est à dire
six cents ans plus tard les gens en
tressant 48 quand la peste est arrivé il
leur fallait six siècles pour avoir un
traitement
donc évidemment il allait mourir bien
que sans traitement alors que nous
savons aujourd'hui que nous aurons un
traitement contre le corona 10 rue sur
maximum dans deux ans c'est intéressant
ce que vous notez déjà vous nous
apprenez plein de choses premièrement et
deuxièmement ça veut dire qu'on est dans
des sociétés aujourd'hui qu'inepte 70
plus le risque on demande à nos
gouvernements de gérer finalement le
risque zéro tout à l'heure vous c'est
nuillé l'action du gouvernement mais
c'est vrai que voilà il ya beaucoup de
sueur sur réaction on n'accepte plus
justement les risques aujourd'hui on est
des sales gosses on est des enfants
gâtés
et puis les collègues ce blog les
écologistes les prophètes de malheur
nous ont convaincus que nous vivons une
époque affreuse alors que l'espérance de
vie et la santé sur terre n'a jamais été
aussi bonne en 1900 l'espérance de vie
sur terre était de moins de 30 ans elle
est aujourd'hui de 71 ans donc que nous
n'avons jamais sur terre une aussi bonne
santé aujourd'hui donc il faut
relativiser le color grenade et russe
mym ce même si c'est une épreuve médical
pour pour la terre la terre ne s'est
jamais aussi bien porté en termes de
qualité de santé d'espérance de vie
la mortalité à la naissance n'a jamais
été aussi faible
la mortalité des enfants n'a jamais été
aussi faible la mortalité par
catastrophe naturelle n'a jamais été
aussi faible
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que le nombre
de morts par catastrophe naturelle a été
divisée par huila depuis l'année 1931
donc oui l'état de santé en 2020 et très
bon par rapport à ce qu'il était dans le
passé donc il ne faut pas insulter
la médecine d'aujourd'hui la médecine
d'aujourd'hui c'est que nous avons
beaucoup beaucoup moins de maladies que
nous vivons beaucoup plus longtemps
qu'avant donc ne jouons pas les sales
gosses tu les sales gosses ingrat
remercions la médecine de fer que nous
n'avons jamais eu une meilleure santé
sur terre quand cette année 2020 mais
c'est vrai que on aime bien fantasmer la
terre comme une espèce de jardin d'éden
qui n'a jamais été qui n'a jamais existé
c'est à dire que c'est c'est vraiment
une attitude très rousseau vice de
penser que la terre serait à l'état de
nature havre comme ça naturellement
hospitalier et que tous les maux de la
terre proviennent de la civilisation de
la mondialisation des interdépendances
de l'industrialisation des voix
écologistes se sont levés pour accuser
l'artificialisation du monde d'exposer
l'humanité à des maladies qui
n'existerait pas lorsqu'on sent qu'ici
la nature sauvage donc les victimes du
paludisme à la périphérie des pays qui
ont asséché leurs zones humides seront
ravis d'apprendre qu'à asséché que
sanctuariser la nature sauvage suffit à
la rendre bienveillante
non la terre n'a jamais été cet éden
hospitalier c'est au contraire la
civilisation le progrès d'ouverture qui
permet d'alléger le fardeau terrestre de
l'homme et de faire en sorte en effet
que notre espèce n'est jamais été aussi
bonne santé
aujourd'hui vous parler d'écologie le
fameux nuage de pollution qui est
traditionnellement au dessus de la chine
a semble-t-il disparu ces dernières
semaines y'a pas de leçons à tirer de ce
constat je pense que c'est une vision
assez cynique c'est à dire que la
pollution c'est la contrepartie
inévitable de la vie c'est à dire que
chaque activité humaine implique un
certain degré de pollution qu'on va
juger plus ou moins acceptable en
fonction des circonstances de l'époque
des technologies disponibles de notre
niveau de richesse dire se féliciter
comme on a pu l'entendre de d'une
réduction de la pollution sans
comprendre qu'il s'agit là de la
contrepartie de l'arrêt d'industrie qui
permettent à des gens de vivre une vie
confortable
je pense que c'est ainsi d'un cynisme
est intolérable et à se dépasser
ac oui assez assez
assez révoltant laurent alexandre
cynisme révoltant vous aussi vous
partagez cet avis les gens juste oublié
ce qu'était la vie jadis l'espérance de
vie à paris elle était de 25 ans 25 ans
et louis 14 a perdu sa dernière devant à
42 ans la vie ton passé était absolument
épouvantable et les gens l'ont oublié
avant la vaccination contre la polio
quand on avait son gamin qui avait la
polio on le mettait dans un poumon
artificiel 7 est absolument atroce et le
plus souvent son gamin mouret on ne
réalise plus l'opinion ne réalisent pas
à quel point la vie était difficile dans
le passé et aujourd'hui les gens
ferghana raison les gens idéalise un
passé qui était épouvantable la vie dans
le patient était épouvantable
il n'y avait pas il n'y avait pas
d'antalgiques on mourait très facilement
de maladie il faut savoir par exemple qu
avant l'invention de l'appendicectomie
en 1888 à lausanne par le docteur
charles kraft sont pour ce temps des
gens qui avaient une appendicite aiguë
mouren et quand on avait son gamin qui
avait une appendicite
on appelait pas le médecin on appelait
le croque mort et le curé jusqu'en 1888
donc n'idéalisons pas le passé
heureusement nous vivons en 2020 la vie
n'a jamais été aussi douce qu'en 2020
nous allons arriver à contourner la
problématique du coronavirus on va
trouver un traitement on est si nous
étions cinquante ans plus tôt je serais
inquiet pour le coronavirus mais avec la
technologie de 2020 nous allons
rapidement limité les dégâts puis
trouver des solutions médicales
vive le progrès et vive la médecine et
en tant que médecin je ne souhaite à
personne je ne souhaite à aucun français
de vivre dans la france 2009 de 1930 ou
de 1950
parce que la médecine y était très
rudimentaire merci on va terminer sur
ces paroles positives ça fait du bien
n'est ce pas merci docteur laurent
alexandre d'avoir été en direct avec
nous merci
sur ce plateau fergane
ziri asa à pardon a dit harry je vais y
arriver d'avoir été avec nos également
c'est la fin